Hi, I'm Ed Mazria.
I'm with a non-profit organization and think-tank
called Architecture 2030.
I'm actually right down the hill here in Santa
Fe.
I'm here at the Global Sustainability Summer
program and I'm teaching one of the sessions,
and one of the things we're focusing on in
the sessions is how to really get a handle
on the built environment, and especially the
building sector, when it comes to climate
change.
So, how are we going to reduce emissions?
How are we going to get to a 50% reduction
by 2030 and then phase out all CO2 emissions
in the built environment by 2050?
So we've gone through all that today, in a
seminar format, and the participants that
come here then work on problems on how to
do that.
So we've issued some problems, we've illustrated
how we've done it, but we want to see what
other ideas come out of this and what the
students and the participants bring to the
problems that we need to solve.